hi my name is jasper i use that pronouns  hi my name is lyanna i use the demon  pronouns this video is how to use our  pronouns so leona uses they them  pronouns in demon pronouns so the first  sentence would be liana is my partner  they are cute and i am theirs i love  them very much and i hope they love  themselves too  for the demon pronouns it would be leona  is my partner d miss q and i belong to  dean i love damon very much and i hope  dean loves demon self too  then interchanging the two would be  lyanna is my partner  they are cute and i am deans  i love demon very much  and i hope they love demon self too  she's she that she's going to be a  linguistics professor that's that's this  is what this is what um grammar  teaching language and grammar that's  what that's what it's going to be pretty  soon